weiß nicht ob ihnen das klar ist es sind
nur noch drei Tage dann entscheidet sich
ob die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
eine Demokratie bleiben oder nicht
endlich geht es mal um was hier noch nie
stand so viel auf dem Spiel bei den
mittürmen Wahlen viele Amis besorgen
sich hört man zum ersten Mal einen
Reisepass um notfalls abhauen zu können
sogar die Freiheitsstatue lässt sich ein
hört man und zwar zu Recht zu Recht
liebe Zuschauer denn Demokratie setzt
schon voraus dass man Wahlergebnisse
anerkennt leider hat aber die Trump
Sekte formalinone es Republikaner
beschlossen Niederlagen grundsätzlich
nicht mehr zu akzeptieren gar nicht mehr
hier carry Lake gouverneurs-kandidatin
für Arizona
starten die hängt schon wieder ja bei
den sogenannten mit terms werden
übrigens auch die Posten der Wahlleiter
neu besetzt also der Typen die bei der
nächsten Präsidentschaftswahl für ihren
Bundesstaat entscheiden ob das Ergebnis
rechtmäßig ist und anerkannt wird und
nicht wenige von denen sind überzeugt
dass Donald Trump der Wahlsieg gestohlen
wurde der mit Terminator hat geschworen
i'll be back und weil die demografische
Entwicklung gegen sie spielt schaffen
seine Republikaner jetzt auf sicher die
Demokratie ab Trunks Kandidaten
handverlesene Idioten und
Verschwörungstheoretiker werden nächste
Woche entweder gewinnen oder wieder
Wahlbetrug schreiben und in Arizona muss
man als Briefwähler an bewaffneten
maskierten Wahlbeobachtern vorbei aber
das ist keine Einschüchterung die
kontrollieren ob auch genug Porto auf
den Brief ist
mein Gott Amis wir Deutschen machen uns
echt sorgen um euch ich meine ihr habt
uns doch die Demokratie geschenkt
zusammen mit dem widerlichen McRib und
David Hasselhoff und jetzt schafft ihr
sie selber wieder ab die Demokratie fast
die Hälfte der Amerikaner glaubt dass es
in den nächsten Jahren zu einem
Bürgerkrieg kommen wird sagen Umfragen
seit dem Sturm aufs Kapitol also einem
lupenreinen Putschversuch ist Gewalt für
viele da ein ein legitimes Mittel der
Politik und selbst harmlos aussehende
republikanerinnen sind zwar
grundsätzlich immer noch irgendwie gegen
Gewalt
andererseits andererseits bin ich jetzt
überzeugt dass man wohl ein Exempel
statuieren muss kennen wir uns
und wir müssen vielleicht auch Leute wie
die Clintons enthaupten
ja wenn es nicht anders geht müssen wir
die Clinton sein
sie hat wahrscheinlich so nach
hausfrauenliste am Kühlschrank kleben
Auto waschen Klopapier kaufen
clintonsköpfen was ist
denn da los das Land gespalten die
Debatte komplett verroht was mit Elon
Musk als twitter-chef und obertroll
bestimmt nicht besser wird in nächster
Zeit gerade erst ist ein Trump Fan bei
Nancy pilosi eingebrochen um der
82-jährigen und ich zitiere wörtlich die
Kniescheiben zu zertrümmern
und weil sie nicht da war muss er mit
dem Kopf ihres Mannes Vorlieben nehmen
das ist doch wirklich alles nur noch
krank woher kommt der Hass zum Beispiel
auf Pelosi gibt's da irgendeine Spur
crazy Nancy crazy Nancy crazy Nancy
Palace
genau crazy Nancy ein Ende bereiten
ausgerechnet Donald Trump and Pelosi
verrückt alte Sprichwort wer im irrenos
sitzt sollte nicht mit Zwangsjacken
werfen
Trump hat gestern gesagt dass er in 2024
sehr sehr sehr sehr wahrscheinlich noch
mal antreten mein Gott bitte nicht schon
wieder diese Opa Battle Trump gegen
beiden ja der sind wir mal ehrlich Joe
Biden ist zwar kein notorischer Lügner
und Narzisst was super ist aber es steht
dann auch nicht direkt für ja sagen wir
mal Zukunft ne wenn Sie verstehen was
ich meine ja ja es ist ja so
es ist ja so der joe ist mit fast 80 der
älteste Präsident aller Zeiten
und findet ohne Navi kaum noch von der
Bühne
warum haben die Demokraten keine anderen
Hoffnungsträger oder wenn ich jemand
weiß ich nicht dennoch lebt irgendwie
sowas
wissen Sie was die USA bräuchten den
Präsi TÜV wirklich die brauchen einen
Präsi TÜV da könnte man doch wunderbar
überprüfen ob die Tauglichkeit noch da
ist Prüfung wie sieht der Kandidat
unsichtbare Menschen und versucht ihnen
die Hand zu schütteln ja wie sicher
wirkte auf dem Fahrrad ohne Stützräder
und wie schlägt er sich ohne Hilfe auf
dem Weg in die Air Force One
geht so
schlimme Bilder wirklich ja und auch
wenn es vielleicht ein bisschen hart
klingt muss man die Frage stellen kann
der Kandidaten noch fehlerfrei bis 13
kommt ungefähr hin oder ja unter Joe
Biden freuen sich die USA über die
niedrigste Arbeitslosenquote seit 50
Jahren gleichzeitig leidet das Land
genau wie wir unter explodierenden
Preisen Inflation überhaupt hat Europa
wenn man darüber nachdenkt wenig Grund
die Nase zu impfen siehe die neuen
Regierungen in Italien oder Schweden ich
behaupte zumindest in Sachen Wahl Spots
sind die Amis immer noch Trendsetter da
ist einiges sogar künstlerisch wertvoll
meint Friedemann Weise
[Musik]
Milliarden von Dollars haben die
Parteien vor den mit terms allein für
Fernsehwerbung ausgegeben und so
unterschiedlich die Wahlwerbespots auch
sind ein Motiv taucht zumindest bei den
Republikanern immer wieder auf Android
Masters
für die us-sonna
takes
is usual
[Musik]
die Queen hatte nur ein Sandwich in Iran
Tasche das ist der Unterschied zum alten
Europa hier denken bei solchen Bildern
viele der primitive Armee mit seinem
krankhaften Waffen Fetisch aber ist es
wirklich so einfach ja das sind viele
Waffen aber es ist auch eine sehr
diverse Gruppe von Menschen von jung bis
alt von Frau bis Mann und von weiß bis
beige und man darf nicht vergessen die
Waffen sind ja nur Symbole für Waffen
oder auch für etwas ganz anderes
richtig hier steht die Waffe für die
rasche Umsetzung der Verkehrswende
dieses Auto wird so schnell keine Straße
mehr verstopfen neben den Waffen ist das
Auto auch ein wiederkehrendes Motiv im
Wahlkampf
wer da nur martialische Drohungen und
dröhnende Motoren hört übersieht die
klare klimapolitische Botschaft es ist
ein Bus der hier dem Individualverkehr
metaphorisch ein Ende setzt ein klares
Signal für öffentliche Verkehrsmittel
und das Auto wird nicht nur verteufelt
es werden auch gleich die nötigen
Alternativen aufgezeigt
hier entsteht die besondere Tiefe durch
das Spiel zwischen Text und Subtext die
Kandidatin spricht über illegale
Einwanderung und zeigt nachhaltige
Mobilität im ländlichen Raum immer
wieder geht es um die Umwelt auch in
diesem wahlspot
auf den ersten Blick ein südstaatenidyll
das kein Klischee auslässt und dann
plötzlich der dystopische Bruch wenn der
Sohn einen toten Fisch aus dem See zieht
unübersehbar eine Hommage an den
avant-film der frühen 60er Jahre doch
leider gibt es neben diesen kleinen Oden
der Filmkunst auch Kandidaten denen
alles egal scheint von Machtgier
getriebene Egomanen die sich offen und
ohne jede Scham als Gangster vor die
Kamera stellen
[Musik]
über 80 also seid bitte nett und freut
euch dass Olaf Scholz nicht
und damit zurück nach Deutschland
hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den Kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen Dank
[Musik]